imagine a map of the mathematical world
it's the product of thousands of years
of human ingenuity from the babylonians
to riemann to the present day
in this world is everything we know
about numbers shapes and their
relationships
there are many mathematical continents
each with its own language and culture
one with a distinguished history is
number theory
it's an unpredictable land of lush
forests full of opportunity with little
secrets hidden everywhere
here they speak the language of
arithmetic
another continent is called harmonic
analysis
it's a place of smooth curves symmetry
and repeating patterns
here mathematical objects speak the
language of signals and waves
for most of history these two continents
have remained distant strangers
mathematicians didn't think there would
be much to gain from trying to travel
between them
but in the last half century something
striking has happened
we've discovered glimpses of an enormous
bridge that seems to connect the
continents as mathematicians build
segments of this bridge they can pass
seemingly intractable problems across it
illuminating them in the process
the full bridge is called the langlens
program
it's one of the biggest projects in
modern mathematical research some even
like to call it a grand unified theory
of mathematics
i'm alex conterovich and i'll be your
guide as we explore some of the patterns
and symmetries suggested by the langlens
program ideas that imply deep powerful
and beautiful connections between the
most fundamental continents of the
mathematical world
in 1967 a 30 year old mathematician
named robert langlins wrote a
deceptively modest letter to his
colleague the famous french number
theorist andre vey
if you are willing to read this as pure
speculation i would appreciate that the
letter said
if not i'm sure you have a wastebasket
handy
to vae's surprise the letter contained a
series of striking conjectures that
predicted something very unlikely a
correspondence between two objects from
completely different fields of math
what langlin suggested seemed stranger
than telepathy how could two objects
indigenous to different mathematical
continents evolved to behave in exactly
the same way
this is the question at the heart of the
langlens program
to understand this mysterious connection
we first have to meet two mathematicians
who studied these objects from opposite
shores
this is srinivasa ramanujan
in 1916 the self-taught indian math
prodigy got very interested in a
particular function now known as the
ramonogen discriminant function
put simply this function multiplies
infinitely many terms together
in ramanujan's time this was already
known to be a special type of function
called a modular form
to see modular forms it's not enough to
look at the real numbers we need to
treat the input as a complex number
which will produce a complex output
[Music]
when we do this the function starts to
reveal its mesmerizing symmetries
modular forms are some of the most
bizarre objects in mathematics they
satisfy so many internal symmetries that
it's surprising that they exist at all
ramanujan wasn't the first to study the
symmetries of modular forms but he was
the first to imagine whether they had
any connection to the distant shores of
number theory
he did this by studying the function
from a different angle
what would happen ramonagen wanted to
know if you multiplied all of its terms
out and collected the coefficients
when he did this romanogen noticed that
the coefficients have a special kind of
predictive power if you know all of the
function's prime coefficients then you
can use them to figure out the rest
for example if you find this coefficient
which is negative 24
and this coefficient which happens to be
252
then i can immediately tell you what the
coefficient of x to the sixth will be
because two times three is six
this pattern always seemed to hold but
ramanujan couldn't prove why
he became obsessed with these numbers
and continued to experiment with them
eventually making more remarkable
conjectures on their behavior
but they were so difficult to prove that
they sat collecting dust
nearly six decades later belgian
mathematician pierre deleon came up with
a brilliant proof of ramonagen's
conjecture earning delena fields medal
delene used the key insight from
langlin's conjectures called
functoriality to bypass the bridge from
harmonic analysis to number theory
but the bridge goes in both directions
now it's time to travel over to the
shores of number theory where the rest
of our story will take shape
in 1637 the french lawyer turned
hobbyist mathematician pierre de fermat
scribbled an equation in his copy of
diophantus's arithmetica
he never offered a proof claiming that
it was too marvelous for the narrow
margins to contain
the theorem featured a polynomial
equation a fundamental object native to
the continent of number theory these are
some of the most basic equations you can
write down just variables with exponents
that are positive whole numbers
you may remember the pythagorean theorem
from school that a right triangle with
sides a b and hypotenuse c will satisfy
this equation
there are lots of integer solutions
here's the note that fermat wrote in the
margins of arithmetica
unlike the pythagorean theorem these
polynomial equations will never have
natural number solutions except of
course if one of the variables is zero
this tantalizingly simple claim came to
be known as ferma's last theorem
for 350 years generations of
mathematicians struggled to prove or
disprove this conjecture
then in the 1990s princeton
mathematician andrew wiles shocked the
world with a breakthrough
standing on the shores of number theory
he began dreaming of a bridge to
harmonic analysis
to understand how wiles built this
bridge we'll first need to meet a
special type of polynomial equation
called an elliptic curve
here is an example of an elliptic curve
you'll notice that it only has two
variables x and y
let's take a look at our elliptic curve
graphed on the cartesian plane
this shows all the pairs of real numbers
x and y that satisfy our equation
but we're not just interested in the
real solutions we also want to make the
problem more interesting by restricting
the domain to find solutions in the
rational numbers that is fractions and
in the integers
to study these solutions it's useful to
consider our elliptic curve from another
perspective
we can use a fantastic tool from number
theory called modular arithmetic it's a
way of counting integers using only the
remainders
we use this kind of math every day when
we tell time on a 12 hour clock
if someone says let's meet at 1 500 you
know they really mean 3 pm because both
15 and 3 when divided by 12 leave the
same remainder
now what if we decided to change our 12
hour clock to a different number say 31
when we do this we change what's called
the modulus
so when the modulus is 31 what's 6
squared
well it should be 36 but on our clock we
see the number 5
because we're 5 hours past high noon
here's the funny thing about modular
arithmetic equations like this which
don't have rational solutions may have
modular solutions since 6 squared is the
same as 5 modulo 31 which means that x
equals 6 solves the equation
now let's go back to our elliptic curve
and try to find modular solutions what
we really care about is how many
solutions there are
here is the graph of all of the modular
solutions of our equation
the dots are the pairs x and y for which
x cubed plus x
plus 17 when divided by 31 leaves the
same remainder as y squared
for a modulus n let's call the number of
solutions b sub n for example when n
equals 31 we have 24 solutions
we can compute these values b sub n for
lots of different moduli n that is
clocks with different hours
this gives us an infinite sequence
now we can make a function by taking
this infinite sequence multiplying each
term by a power of x
and summing them all up
the result is called an infinite power
series which is like a polynomial but
with an infinite number of terms
right about now you might be wondering
what's the point of making this function
when wiles began building the bridge to
harmonic analysis he used some important
scaffolding built decades earlier by
three mathematicians named taniyama
shimura and bay
they had predicted that for any elliptic
curve the resulting function would be a
modular form an object with the same
kinds of symmetries that ramanujan
studied on the land of harmonic analysis
so since we just created a function from
an elliptic curve
shouldn't it be a modular form in
disguise
remember that ramonagen started with a
function that he knew was a modular form
and tried to learn something about its
coefficients here we have a function and
we know its coefficients since they come
from counting solutions on the elliptic
curve with different clocks
but what we don't know is whether our
function is in reality a modular form
so let's graph it on the unit disk and
see what happens
incredibly it does seem to be a modular
form
but is this just a fluke
this is the question wiles had to answer
to finish building the bridge
he had to prove that every elliptic
curve is intimately related to a modular
form
but wait a second why are we talking
about elliptic curves when we started
out trying to understand fermat's last
theorem which is a completely different
type of polynomial equation
german mathematician gerhard frye made a
key connection here he observed that if
fermat's equation did have a
hypothetical solution in other words a
counter example that is a to the p plus
b to the p was indeed equal to c to the
p for p greater than two
then you could make this elliptic curve
which seems to have extremely bizarre
properties in particular when you create
the infinite power series out of it it
would not have the symmetries required
to be a modular form
this means that if fermat's last theorem
were false then the taneyama shimura of
a conjecture would also be false because
the counter-example to forma's last
theorem would make an elliptic curve
which is not modular
[Music]
so when wiles and his student richard
taylor proved that every elliptic curve
does indeed produce an infinite power
series which is modular they also showed
that fry's elliptic curve can't exist
which means that a solution to fermat's
equation can't exist either
and that's how wiles proved for ma's
last theorem
it's one of the craziest proofs by
contradiction ever
by showing that elliptic curves give
rise to modular forms wiles built the
bridge from number theory to harmonic
analysis and by studying the special
predictive power of the coefficients in
modular forms ramonogen and later delene
used the bridge from harmonic analysis
to number theory
these proofs are some of the most
monumental achievements in modern
mathematics but they're also just a tiny
sliver of the vast construction project
that is the langlens program
langlin's ideas have traveled to the
shores of algebraic geometry
representation theory and quantum
physics where mathematicians will be
building bridges for years to come
nobody knows how far langland's vision
extends but many mathematicians agree
that it has the potential to solve some
of the most intractable problems of our
time
someday the langlen's program may reveal
the deepest symmetries between many
different continents a kind of grand
unified theory of the mathematical world
that answers the most fundamental
questions we have about numbers
[Music]
[Music]
you